all right let's talk about uh a new
crypto fund andreessen horowitz a16z
raised 4.5 billion dollars for their
fourth crypto fund they now have raised
more than 7.6 billion dollars in total
crypto funds this is obviously a massive
deal given what's happening in the
market today crypto assets have fallen
off a cliff essentially all of them
whether it's bitcoin ethereum things in
web 3 venture capital investments etc
the market is down tremendously over the
last few weeks and over the last few
months so andreessen coming out and
saying hey look we're not stopping we
are raising a brand new fund a
multi-billion dollar fund a 4.5 billion
dollar fund i think speaks to their
conviction in the space and they're
basically saying hey we are not going to
be deterred we do not want to uh stop
investing in web3 we think that this is
a big innovation area we are going to
continue to bet on asset prices uh
skyrocketing and so forth so whether
it's web3 crypto bitcoin ethereum
whatever you want to call it they are
raising money to go continue to invest
in the space they are betting on digital
assets continuing to grow over time and
they are saying that this is a bear
market but they will be involved heavily
and at the same time if you look back on
all the major companies openc et cetera
and and coinbase and so others like a
lot of these companies uh were actually
started during bear markets so this is
actually probably an incredible time for
them to be raising 4.5 billion not only
for themselves but their lps and others
to go out and deploy some of this
capital when other money is not doing
that and it's less competitive in these
rounds and they're able to get better
valuations and the multiples start to
compress and so forth it's probably
extremely strategic if you have the
ability to raise capital and to invest
capital and you believe in this asset
class long term to go do exactly what
they're doing which is raising billions
of dollars and going to invest in good
founders with good track records that
have the opportunity to build massive
multi-billion dollar businesses and
that's exactly what they're doing what
do you think about it i think this is
the largest fund that they've ever had
which is a key note to their conviction
in the crypto space i think that these
times downturn times are times where
people that have very high conviction in
something see opportunity and they see
the hey we can get a little bit lower
valuation on this company we can pour
more money into it clearly investors are
not scared if they were able to go out
and raise four point philly 4.5 billion
dollars almost quite easily i would say
uh but andreessen horowitz and a16z is
legendary in this space right they make
they make bets and they win um and they
make very very good and very very smart
bets and then they pile on to the
winners and i think that's what they can
do with this fund is with 4.5 billion
dollars i think 1.5 will be allocated to
seed investments and 3 billion will be
venture investments so they have that
ability to hey let's go pour on the
winners that are either having tough
times or even striving in down times um
and then that's what they can do with
this 4.5 billion dollars well i think
the the biggest advantage that they
probably have is uh their name and their
ability to raise capital right now
because even if you don't think that
they're good investors the fact that
they have so much capital now to deploy
in this market is a massive advantage
because of everything that i mentioned
previously which are multiples are
compressing the rounds are less
competitive founders are looking to
raise money for the long term and
they're willing to accept terms that
aren't as great as they maybe could have
gotten six or 12 months ago because of
that because they want to make sure that
their business doesn't run out of money
the number one job of any founder in the
world is literally just don't run out of
money because that's when the company
dies so a16z sitting there now with 4.5
billion dollars and signaling in the
market we're open for business we're
going to continue to invest in these
companies through a downturn through a
bear market whether it last six months
12 months 18 months 24 months or even
longer they're going to continue to
deploy capital and i think that's a
massive advantage for them relative to
other funds because of their ability to
go raise money and now they can invest
in a better terms than they would have
gotten six or 12 months ago so this is
really where they're going to make some
of their fortunes right and when we
emerge from this bear market like they
assume that we're going to because of
their conviction on the sector my bet is
that there's i don't know if it's one
two three four maybe even more companies
that they invested in during this
downturn that they got really favorable
terms on and made a boatload of money on
because of their ability to use their
name and their experience and their
investments in their track record to go
raise billions of dollars so i think
it's incredibly intelligent and a smart
move to do it at this time period
obviously this has probably been been
being worked on for you know weeks or
months at this point
but it is convenient timing now with the
downturn because if you're an investor
that's looking to allocate capital to
the space long term
it's a great time to be doing that
because of everything that we mentioned
yeah
a16 z just i just they make bets and
they they make very very smart bets and
you can see that their track record just
speaks for itself with the companies
that they've invested in um i believe
they're wearing corn coin base and a
bunch of early infrastructure plays
early on when people were doing tokens
in you know 2017 2018 um they were
already looking at equity deals um and i
think it just speaks to their forward
thinking they're they're they're all in
on crypto at this point right like web 2
or web3 they're just they're all in
they're pouring money into it um
[Music]
and we're going to see if it plays off
in the next few years hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time